Oui.
Dépêchez-vous, s’il vous plaît, parce que ça va commencer, là.
Ah, déjà ?
Et c’est par où ?
Mais par là-bas !
Bah qu’est-ce que c’est que ça, là ?
Bah c’est le code Rousseau.
Non mais le tricheur, je rêve ?
Mais pas du tout, je révisais dans le métro !
Non mais il n’y a pas de ça dans la salle d’examen. Vous me donnez ça, s’il vous plaît !
Un tank garé en double-file obstrue le passage.
"A", j’utilise mes rétrofusées pour faire un écran de fumée.
"B", je le descends parce qu'il vient de tuer mon coéquipier...
T’es tombé pour quoi, toi ?
Je me suis fait flasher à 8 046 km/h, sur l’A6.
Classique.
Excusez-moi... Vous êtes Batman ?
Correct.
J’étais persuadé que vous n’existiez pas.
Ouais ?
Bah pareil.
Ouais.
Demi-tour, du coup.
Dans mon rétroviseur, un dragon me fait des appels de flammes.
Daenerys du typhon de la Maison Targaryen, première du nom...
C’est la meuf de Games of Thrones ?
Oui-oui.
Reine de Meereen, Reine des Andals, Reine de Rhoynar et des Premiers Hommes. Suzeraine des Sept Couronnes et Grande Protectrice du Royaume...
-Elle est belle.
Khaleesi de la Grande Mer Herbeuse. Mère des Dragons, L'Imbrûlée, Mhysa…
Je voudrais savoir si je pourrai aller faire un petit popo, en fait.
Ah c’est sûr que là, ça démystifie un peu, hein.
Fallait y penser avant. Je suis désolé, Madame.
Et lui, c’est Kylo Ren ?
Oui-oui.
Et depuis quand il est examinateur d’auto-école ?
Toi, tu es Oui-Oui ?
Oui-oui.
Ah c’est bien ce qui me semblait.
Sous le stress des embouteillages...
Un passager déchire sa chemise…
Daenerys du typhon de la Maison Targaryen, première du nom. Reine des Andals, Reine de Meereen...
Vous pourriez pas dire tout simplement la meuf avec les dragons, là ?
Suzeraine des Sept Couronnes, Grande Protectrice...
Non mais ce serait plus simple pour tout le monde si c’était…
Ecoutez!  Si vous me coupez encore une fois je recommence depuis le début.
Khaleesi de la Grande Mer Herbeuse, Mère des Dragons, L'Imbrûlée…
Et ben, je sais plus ce que je voulais dire maintenant !
Donc, euh...
Si, pardon ! Excusez-moi ! Ça me revient, d’un coup, là.
Daenerys du typhon de la Maison Targaryen … qui se rassoit parce que, vraiment là, n’a pas ses dragons à dispo, là.
Voilà.
Mon ennemi juré m’a fait prendre des champignons stupéfiants...
Qu’est-ce qu’il fait Aladdin ? Il se tripote la nouille ?
Oui-oui.
Non, non.
J’étais en train de sortiiiir... Le génie de la laaaaaampe...
Qu’est-ce que vous êtes en train de faire, là ?
Vous trichez.
Moi ? Non, pas du tout.
J’ai dit… On… Ne… Triche… Pas… Pendant… L’examen !
Même pas peur.
Ah Oui-Oui… bah Non-non. Toi, dégages !
Ah ! Alors, vous…
Et ben 40/40, c’est un perfect. Félicitations, vous êtes le seul à l’avoir, hein ?
Ah, super ! Je vais pouvoir livrer tous mes cadeaux, et remplir le cœur de tous les enfants du monde entier.
Alors, calmos tout de suite... Parce que ça, c’est le code.
C'est l’épreuve théorique. Maintenant, il faut passer la pratique...
La conduite. Donc... Ouais, j’ai un créneau en Février, mi-Février. Ça vous va ?
C’est impossible ! Comment je fais, moi, pour livrer mes cadeaux ?
Ah, attendez ! J’ai peut-être un mec qui pourrait vous dépanner.
Bah il a le permis et il aime pas trop son taff actuel, donc, ça pourrait le faire.
Ouais? J’ai ça.
Je vous donne son 06 ?
Les enfants, les cadeaux sont arrivés !
Je suis ton Père...
Noël...